[Música]
[Aplausos]
anamara moranguinho que falar um pouco
sobre esse mundo que existe para as
pessoas trans né
ficou muito colocar o eu fico muito
pensando a sefaz dois anos e meio apenas
que eu pedi pra primeira pessoa a me
chamar de amara dois anos e meio que eu
comece uma transição que começa a
construir uma identidade feminina que eu
começo a me pensar de outra forma que
não a forma que o genital tinha previsto
pra mim o mundo que encontrei a partir
de então é bastante diferente pensar por
exemplo que dez anos atrás quando estava
no segundo ano da graduação de letras
nenhuma experiência profissional
anterior que me qualificar se eu fui
procurar emprego e eu acabei contratado
ainda existia para a sociedade enquanto
o homem naquele momento acabei
contratado como professor de literatura
do importante colégio da cidade nenhuma
experiência profissional qualifique
qualificasse segundo ano de graduação de
letras ou seja nenhuma nenhuma grande
intimidade ainda com literatura né
mas já tinha emprego ao meu dispor hoje
dez anos depois terminando o doutorado
em uma das universidades mais
importantes do país na unicamp estudando
um dos autores mais difíceis da
literatura ocidental james joyce nenhum
colégio e contrataria como professora
nenhum colégio teria coragem de me
contratar como professora porque
inclusive coragem não é uma palavra que
costuma acompanhar é uma palavra que não
está muito presente quando a gente pensa
em escola escola sempre muito associada
à reprodução de paradigmas na reprodução
de estereótipos locais de violência todo
mundo que não está no padrão zinho mais
absurdo possível né todas essas pessoas
vão ser violentadas na escola então e
travestis
mais do que ninguém né e não conseguem
encontrar mim viver nesse lugar de
professora
hoje não consegue por mais que seja
muito melhor professora do que eu fui
dez anos atrás por mais que seja muito
mais capacitadas do que eu fui dez anos
atrás e aí é isso tudo me leva a pensar
por que porque seria tão incomum
tive eu eu poderia existir nesse lugar e
não é já que estou na universidade já
que estou me formando já que estou
dentro desse processo de aprendizagem é
a meritocracia nesse momento entra em
xeque não é porque ela vai falar pra
você se esforça que você chega onde você
quiser e de repente percebo que dez anos
atrás quando não estiver sem nada eu já
estava lá e hoje como começa uma
transição não consigo chegar a lugar
nenhum sabe estando muito mais preparada
para ocupar esse posto esse cargo
emprego e aí o que me vem à cabeça
justamente a forma como a sociedade
entende travestis e transexuais essa
narrativa única que nos ingesta que nos
mobiliza que faz com que a gente seja
reduzida a nada que faz com que a gente
só possa ocupar as margens ocupá é esses
lugares que a gente não considera nem
lugares né então tá as narrativas que
engessam que mobilizam não são
particularidade peculiaridade nossa
muitos outros grupos todos os outros
grupos que estão de alguma forma sendo
excluídos oprimidos eles também são
vítimas são reféns dessas narrativas né
então a gente pode pensar por exemplo
mulheres metade da população mais de
metade da população não é o quanto o
machismo não a destra o nosso olhar pra
antes e buscar a mulher beleza do que
inteligência então primeira coisa que a
gente vai ver vai focar lá né
mas será que a mulher bonita fez será
que ela fez à a maquiagem bem será que
ela tá com uma roupa bonita será que ela
está em forma
será aquela mulher padrão será que ela
está de acordo com os padrões de beleza
da feminilidade gente né
primeiro a gente vai ver isso depois se
sobrar tempo estiver interesse e boa
vontade a gente vai abrir um pouco a
escuta para ver se essa mulher
inteligente essa mulher que diz algo
para além do óbvio né e se ela disser
ela vai ser questionada ela vai ser
desafiado o tempo todo ela vai ter que
provar muito mais importante muito mais
poderosas hc inteligente do que qualquer
homem tá conseguiu ocupar os mesmos
espaços que os homens porque ela os
nomes não serão tão questionadas homens
não será o primeiro vamos ficasse tão
bonito seria você está dentro do padrão
e depois vamos deixar
é depois vamos ver se está falando
alguma coisa que preste
no primeiro só vai conseguir prestar
atenção no que está falando
já a partir do pressuposto de que talvez
ele esteja falando algo que preste
e aí a gente pode pensar por exemplo
também no quanto o racismo à destra o
nosso olhar para reconhecer a pessoa
negra perigo netão um monte de amigos do
movimento negro de jack que eles trazem
esse relato muito delicado é de como é
existir uma sociedade onde você vai
andando na rua e as pessoas vão te vendo
como ameaça como perigo vão retrair do
corpo vão escondendo bolsa sabe o tempo
inteiro não importa quem seja a pessoa
viu uma pessoa negra
você já vai com vai o seu corpo treme
seu corpo aprendeu reagir dessa forma
isso é racismo esse é o racismo
adestrando o nosso corpo os nossos
sentimentos
isso é uma forma de violência
pesadíssima
isso acontece também com travestis né
quando olham pra nós
a primeira coisa que pensa não é nossa
que pessoa inteligente o que pessoa
brilhante outra pessoa qualquer coisa
que seja só conseguem ver uma coisa não
se consegue ver esse futuro está
destinado para nós agir no momento em
que agente negou o que o genital
decretou para o nosso corpo porque
parece que existe um gene tal que
ninguém vê ninguém tem acesso digital
anuncia que vai transar com a pessoa né
mas a gente acha que vené ea gente esse
genital ele tem o poder de decretar um
futuro para esse corpo e esse futuro tem
que ser obedecido e se não for obedecido
aí dessa pessoa
eu lembro dentro da universidade dois
anos e meio atrás quando começa a minha
transição uma das primeiras frases que
houve uma pessoa que não acompanhou toda
a pré história desse primeiro dia nesse
dia que eu chego e peço meio que pedimos
desculpas será que vocês poderiam por
favor me chamar de amara hoje não peço
hoje eu coloco meu nome à mara hoje eu
sou outra pessoa naquele momento eu
ainda estava dando os primeiros passos
engatinhando eu lembro que essa pessoa
que não acompanhou toda essa trajetória
ela chega pra mim
ele viu num dia que estava com o tênis
rosa uma calça jeans e uma blusa do bob
esponja muito mau gosto
garanto eu era essa pessoa começa e essa
pessoa olha pra mim e falou nossa
surpresa né com está vivendo daquela
forma mas não é uma surpresa do mau
gosto da minha roupa né
era uma nossa que aconteceu você vai
virar prostituta ela olhou para minha
blusa do bob esponja olhou pra minha
calça jeans e meu tênis rosa e viu uma
prostituta e não era a roupa que estava
dizendo para ela que eu poderia ser uma
prostituta era o fato de eu ter negado o
destino que o meu genital decretou pra
mim isso continua sendo a grande é um
dos maiores pesos que essa sociedade
carrega né
aquele medo sempre constante da gente
negar essa ordem que o genital tempo nós
né
e aí fico pensando talvez seja isso o
que surpreendeu tantas pessoas quando me
lancei candidato a vereadora na minha
cidade eu sair na rua para conversar com
pessoas sobre política
ninguém nunca foi parado na rua para
conversar sobre política por uma
travesti já foram parados por mulheres
se expor o homem se para uma travessia
jamais isso é muito surpreendente se via
nos olhos das pessoas aquele brilho pela
surpresa de igual uma travesti que fala
de política uma travesti que está aqui
vindo falar sobre como é que a gente vai
lutar por uma campinas mais segura para
mulheres lgbts
nossa que é interessante isso né aí
ficavam surpresos ao ver o brilho nos
olhos das pessoas eu tinha intenção de
em quanto mais a falar se mais pessoas
se sentiam surpreendidos o tempo inteiro
surpreendidas porque elas jamais
esperariam isso de uma travesti
jamais isso é reflexo também da
transfobia
eu posso aqui colocando pra vocês é que
nossa olha só que legal as pessoas
paravam para ouvir conseguia falar com
as pessoas mas isso também é reflexo da
transfobia
isso é reflexo do quanto espera um pouco
de nós não esperam nada então qualquer
travesti que isso surpreenda um pouco e
nossa meu deus olha só sabe falar sabe é
sempre dentro dessa lógica e
é interessante pensar né como é que uma
travesti vai falar de transformar
campinas ou qualquer outra cidade uma
cidade mais segura pra travestis bom mas
as travestis são o perigo das cidades né
é dentro dessa lógica que a sociedade
opera vendo a gente como figuras que
ocupam a marginalidade figuras excluídas
socialmente figuras que estão nos não
lugares nos não empregos figuras que não
têm família figuras que não tem moral e
aí dentro desse lugar é dentro de si não
lugar como é que a gente vai pensar que
a gente precisa se preocupar com a conta
com uma cidade segura para essas figuras
nessas pessoas para elas é um pouco
inesperado nunca se perguntaram o que
elas estão sofrendo o que a gente está
vendo o que a gente está sentindo a
cidade como é a vida que a gente tem
direito como é a cidade aqui a gente tem
direito
e aí eu fico pensando é como mudou
drasticamente do dia antes da mara
depois da mara e foi muito radical e não
foi simplesmente um depois que eu disse
que só a mara foi depois que o outro
mileu como a mara antes que eu precisar
se abrir a boca
o que eu quero dizer com isso eu quero
dizer que quando o meu corpo passou a
dizer para o outro essa informação antes
que eu precisasse oferecer essa
informação aí começaram eu comecei a ver
esse outro mundo que existia esse outro
mundo que estava ali sendo é sendo o
mundo que existe para travestismo e aí
como era esse mundo era o mundo do
assédio onipresente então você vai
andando na rua
citando metrô citando ônibus e de
repente tem um braço tem uma mão que
você não sabe muito bem está tocando não
se sente que é um braço e encostando em
você de forma esquisita
o machismo ensina isso pra gente também
ensina a gente a duvidar das nossas
percepções ensina a gente até dúvidas
isso que a gente está vivendo de
violência é realmente uma violência é
então nossa que coisa da minha cabeça ou
será que realmente tem um braço
encostando na minha bunda de forma
esquisita
a verdade é antes da minha transição eu
nunca tive essa dúvida antes da minha
transição
nunca ninguém encostou de forma
esquisita no meu corpo
nunca ninguém tocou o meu corpo sem a
minha permissão ea partir desse momento
como me vêem como uma figura e só serve
para a precariedade para a marginalidade
só serve para a exclusão só serve para
ser usada é só dessa forma que consegue
conceber então vão achar inclusive que
vai ser do meu agrado
se me tocar em essa pessoa que chega no
meu ouvido e diz uma coisa obscena diz
quanto quer que deseja no corpo na cama
ou qualquer coisa mais implicavam wes a
pessoa acha que eu vou gostar de escutar
isso porque na competição dessa pessoa
eu sou tão desejada indesejadas ou tão
abjeta que qualquer pessoa que se digne
a demonstrar o desejo por mim eu vou
ficar muito
o autocarro que obrigada vamos agora
onde a vida é entre dessa lógica que
opera
mas não é só esse assédio que acontece
na minha vida existe também outros tipos
de assédio não a metralhadora de olhares
que vive também toda pessoa trans centra
no espaço e aquele monte de pescoço
pescoços pescoço que vão girando
procurando você né o tempo inteiro às
vezes não são olhares de hostess de
hostilidade olhares agressivos às vezes
não são às vezes olhares curiosos apenas
olhares que querem entender o que você é
mas nesse desejo de entender o que você
é esses olhares estão dizendo que você é
estranho que você esquisito que você não
faz sentido e que eles têm o direito de
olhar até entender o que você é ou deixa
de ser e nós qual é o nosso dever nisso
ser olhados calar e deixar que nos olhem
deixar que façam o que quiserem fazer
então é o tempo inteiro esses olhares
que estão de alguma forma dizendo que
você não devia estar ali ou centro
dentro de uma loja e aquele monte de
olhar os suspeitos você anda na rua e
aquele monte de olhares tentando te
compreendendo olhares olhares olhares o
tempo todo olhares e quando nos olhares
a gente vem
o assédio dos toques a gente vem pro
xingamentos que também são bastante
comuns né
é engraçado que existem dois tipos de
financiamento que são completamente
contraditórios mas que dentro dessa
cultura de colocar a travesti no não
lugar colocar ela
sei lá em qualquer lugar que seja a
gente não consegue entender muito bem
essa figura né
acaba fazendo sentido sei lá né então de
um lado a gente vai escutar alguém
abaixar o vidro do carro e sente a
necessidade de gritar quando vi a gente
passando na rua é homem
esse cara vai sentir a necessidade de
gritar isso é homem e com isso está
dizendo que ele está dizendo qual é o
nosso genital ele está dizendo qual é a
ordem que o nosso genital deu pro nosso
corpo que a gente negocia a ordem mas ao
mesmo tempo teve outro cara e vai
abaixar o outro vidro do carro e queria
gritar para nós
virar homem e citam gritando pra gente
vira homem também tem uma coisa meio
esquisita é porque é como se tivessem
sendo que a gente não é homem então
queremos que a gente seja homem e é
nesse momento em que a gente vai
percebendo que ser homem é não só uma
mera decorrência do genital que a pessoa
tem né
a nossa cultura é muito complexa a gente
não tá vendo genitais pra gente tá
pressupondo genitais mas a gente tem
essa impressão ea gente tem de se esse
desejo de que o corpo espelhe esse
genital que a gente não pode ver a gente
precisa disso é que precisa dessa
segurança está conversando com alguém e
saber genital que a pessoa tenha a gente
precisa tempo inteiro a gente não
consegue lidar com pessoas que a gente
não sabe o genital que tenha eu lembro
inclusive uma figura uma das
experiências mais importantes da minha
vida foi quando eu tinha 15 16 anos
ainda existiam como homem da sociedade
começo da internet no brasil eu estava
lá no bate papo e surge uma figura que
não sei muito bem ser a travesti ou
mulher trans
eu só sabia que existe uma diferença
entre as duas e fiquei com vergonha de
perguntar qual que ela era não me lembro
hoje sabia que tinha alguma coisa com
gene com o cirurgia também não queria
saber não queria dizer pra ela perguntar
né
chico diaz e desrespeitoso olha só
quinze anos atrás achei que podia ser
desrespeitoso perguntar qual genital
latinha
se ela me contasse o rock se ela não me
contasse a questão era menina
a gente troca telefone a gente conversa
horas e horas da madrugada e eu querendo
lá eu toda inexperiente toda virgem mas
querendo posar de maiores de bam bam bam
do sexo né
eu falei pra ela e aí ela falava então
você entende né
é bom de cama tu disse pra mim que você
vai fazer com meu corpo e eu falava que
ia beijar os seios dela ea beijar a
barriga dela ea beijar o quadril na coxa
e joelho e eu pulava genital
eu ficava esperando ela me dizer qual
genital ela tinha e ela nunca me disse
com a genitália tinha meses conversando
não tinha webcam não tinha foto no
computador ninguém scanner em casa nunca
soube o genital que ela tinha percebe o
quanto é perturbador essa história eu me
relacionei com uma pessoa sem nunca
saber que genital latinha é é isso é
esse tipo de experiência que vai começar
a ser cada vez mais cotidiana à medida
que as pessoas trans começarem ao poder
ocupar a sociedade a partir do momento
que a gente poder está em todos os
espaços e não mais só na margem
essa é uma realidade que vai começar a
perturbar muita gente desafiar e vai
aguçar a curiosidade das pessoas hoje em
dia ainda não é tão simples tem uma
resposta dessas né então se você chega
em uma festa e você vai dar em cima de
uma pessoa trans essa pessoa sttrans
pode ficar em pânico porque ela vai ter
sempre com aquele medo
será que a pessoa sabe que eu sou trans
e se eu disser pra ela que eu sou trans
o que vai convencer um mundo que virá
pra mim a partir de então então eu vou
poder ser chumbada pelo resto da festa
inteira eu vou poder ser agredida por
essa pessoa porque eu enganei ela porque
de repente ela vai se dar conta de que
ela sentiu desejo tesão por um pessoa
que negou essa ordem que o genital deu
então é sempre muito delicado a situação
em que nos colocam a gente está sempre
na berlinda a gente nunca sabe
exatamente como responder
chegam perto quando querem demonstra um
desejo gente será que este pressupõe que
ele sabe que a gente avisa e na hora que
for pra transar só porque enquanto
rolando só beijo
sabe por que essa genital gente está
dando beijo mas não precisam saber disso
né porque se souberem depois a nossa
situação é ainda mais perigosa né
então eu trouxe aqui essas provocações
para vocês entenderem um pouquinho do
mundo que a gente vive o mundo que só
existe para nós que negamos essas ordens
que o corpo de como o corpo deverá ser
de como a gente devia existir em
sociedade
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]